preparado durante décadas el protocolo
para la muerte de la reina Isabel es un
asunto que marcha sincrónicamente sin
dejar nada al azar el jueves se puso en
marcha la operación unicornio debido a
que la reina murió en su residencia
privada en Escocia Carlos ya viajó a
Londres para reunirse con la primera
ministra listros y comenzar los
preparativos del funeral se dirigió a la
nación mientras entraba en vigor la
operación marea de primavera que
supervisa el proceso de ascenso al Trono
de la obra Rey Carlos III en Escocia el
féretro de la reina será trasladado en
un tren especial desde balmoral hasta
edimburgo y el Palacio de Hollywood y
después a la catedral de San Gil donde
los dolientes podrán presentar sus
respetos luego los restos de la reina
comenzarán su viaje en el tren real
hasta Londres pero si el féretro no
puede viajar en tren la operación
overstary entrará en acción y el féretro
irá en avión
una vez en Londres el cuerpo de la reina
volverá a la sala del trono del Palacio
de buckingham el día 6 se celebrará un
homenaje público en el Palacio de
Westminster donde los restos de la reina
permanecerán en Capilla ardiente en el
Westminster Hall durante varios días al
igual que su padre Jorge vi el funeral
se celebrará el día 10 en la abadía de
Westminster con la asistencia de 2000
invitados y familiares habrá un momento
de silencio de dos minutos en toda la
nación y la campana del big ben sonará
cuando termine el funeral de estado la
reina será enterrada junto a su difunto
marido Felipe en la capilla de San Jorge
del castillo de Windsor